[Applause]
after becoming the king of late night
greg gutfeld finally decided to take a
day off
so he asked the second funniest person
at fox to fill in for him
but killmead said he wasn't available
so you're stuck with me
my deepest condolences go out to you the
audience you thought you were getting
gut-felled instead
you're getting someone taller
better looking
and someone who didn't get fired from a
ton of magazines
you got waters instead
this is like
[Music]
it's like buying tickets to see jerry
seinfeld
and carrot top takes the stage
now i give you your money back but i
found out gut fell doesn't charge
anybody to come see the show
which makes sense
but there's a silver lining unlike a
normal show none of tonight's jokes will
go over your head
that i promise you
it's me
and it's an honor to step into greg's
shoes today
even though it kind of hurts
because he's a size six
greg's been on a hot streak recently so
he needs a break
a number one best seller a new house a
baby boy
wait that's me
think greg would want a baby
finally someone in his life who's
shorter than he is
also someone to laugh at his poop jokes
greg has a strange sense of humor
doesn't he
it's almost like there's something
beneath the surface that he wants to
tell us
here are my latest candidates for my
personal assistant this is hans
this is lars and this is clive hey i
hope you all had a good weekend mine
wasn't so bad i spent most of it working
on my abs with my personal trainer
[Music]
i'm the one on the bottom
for a change well i work out but i don't
use weights i use the body weight of my
workout partner i have him straddle me
on my back and then i do squat thrusts
wanna you wanna go work out
oh i don't have my workout clothes
you won't need anything
[Music]
not that there's anything wrong with
that
people say that greg's masking his
feminine instincts by constantly talking
about guns
ribs
and death metal
and by people i mean me
now our sources think greg took off
today because he's transitioning
to what exactly
unclear
but a new symbol has been added to the
acronym
lgbtq it's now
lgbtq exclamation
greg's probably at a gender reveal party
tonight
his own
all kidding aside the real reason greg
isn't here today is because it's his
birthday
[Music]
besides 30 year old women and anyone in
the biden administration during a crisis
who takes off on their birthday
greg does apparently
yet much like sleepy joe greg's changed
his position
we'd like to wish our executive producer
megan albano a very happy birthday oh
i'm the one that delivered that news
because i am her favorite host
wait a minute is that why she's not here
today did she take today off because
it's her birthday you know how i feel
about that
so
besides flip-flopping greg and joe biden
have so much in common
their love for hunter
their advanced age
actually biden looks a little younger
than greg in that
and of course the thing they have most
in common
hair plugs
would someone secure about their hair
obsessed over someone else's hair this
much
jesse waters has saved thousands of
lives just by the amount of hairspray he
uses every day
maybe that's how he saved the world his
hair is like an extension cord thick
dark and full of plugs congrats on the
book it's gonna buy you a lot of hair
gel or jesse waters condemning hair gel
like jesse's hair enough product to keep
jesse water's hair standing on end for
eternity so just like joe greg called a
lid today
and i want to be as respectful to greg
as possible while i sit in his chair
wait
what is this
oh just tack a bit what's this stack of
papers doing here
but i really wanted to pay homage to
greg tonight
i even wanted to dress like him so
i peeked in his closet just to get a
little inspiration
filling in for gutfeld tonight
gotta dress the part let's see what he's
got in his closet
pretty nice
dark pants slim fit
i'm almost there blue blazer white shirt
i just got to get the black tie
oh these are perfect
nailed it
this segment was brought to you by baby
gap
and they say imitation is the highest
form of flattery
i'm trying to look and act as much like
greg as possible so
after the show i'm gonna go drink wine
alone
and text dana
i also searched his desk to find some of
his famous notes to use on the show
but
they were all love letters to cat
cat seriously contact hr immediately
this guy is sick
i wrote those about myself okay trying
to work on my self-esteem
it's iris he couldn't make it here
tonight
i'm sorry but a source just sent us some
very exclusive footage here's what tyrus
is up to right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
but in all seriousness i love greg like
i love my assistant
that much
gigi's the man funniest guy i know
i don't really know that many people but
it's a compliment
exclamation point is a huge hit
he's a prolific author
great co-host and did you guys hear
he just interviewed donald trump
way to go gutfeld
quite the achievement
you are the last fox host to interview
trump
in fact great greg might be the last
host in america to interview donald
trump
greg didn't even like trump when he was
running for president
and then i remember that greg didn't
even like me before i started hosting
the five
just another thing he has in common with
biden
terrible instincts
greg didn't think the coronavirus was
going to be that big of a deal
actually that was me
in all honesty greg saw it coming
which is something nobody has ever said
about greg you know because he's little
you can hardly see him
greg is so tiny brian stelter gave him a
nickname
the invisible enemy
but as your doctor told you gutfeld size
doesn't matter
it's what you do with it that counts
and you've done a lot
more than any of us
[Music]
mostly because
you're so old
you've had more time to do stuff
but also because you're such a hard
worker and as they say when you don't
have talent you have to make up for it
with hard work
so way to go buddy
give it your best
and when your best isn't good enough
just do what i do
add a movie clip to make it funnier
i'm kind of a big deal
now that's comedy
stealing other people's material
kind of like what greg does with scott
adams
[Laughter]
speaking of comedy not everything is
funny gutfeld
know your audience
your cackle kinda reminds me of kamala
i don't i don't think it really turned
out that way
this show
uh stay in that voice so hard yeah it
would be a good idea and you're like
[Laughter]
so i've heard
greg this is really weird hey so let's
move on
you know let's start with the positives
really interesting question out of the
box idea
i want to talk about simon schuster
first
[Laughter]
we're going to keep
tonight yeah it's on assignment
read the room dude
covering up your insecurities with
comedy is what stand-up comedians do
that's not you
you know you don't do stand-up because
you have something that stand-up
comedians don't have
notes and a teleprompter
so happy birthday greg i know you're
watching because you have nothing else
to do
[Music]
and i was as mean as possible just so
you'll never ask me to host again
[Applause]
[Music]
let's welcome our guests tonight she
posed for more pictures with her guns
out than sylvester stallone paul
nyle.com editor and fox news contributor
katie padlett
and he'll be the mayor to have a special
task force comprised of rescue cats new
york city republican mayoral candidate
curtis sleewa
poison control recommends his jokes to
induce vomiting
freighter and comedian joe machi
and she's the one cat
even the aspca won't shelter
fox news contributor cat tim
[Music]
all right cat now unlike greg i actually
wrote that monologue myself
how do you feel about gunfield taking a
day off
you know
greg is really really good at um finding
talent
get people to work for him
yes he is like me i'm very funny and
smart right i'm not just a pretty face
um
and then joe mackey
who is so funny
that
last night at gutfeld's birthday party
for about an hour i had to hear my
husband try to convince him to go to
sandals resorts with them two alone
oh wow
that's how funny joe mackey convincing
no
it was my idea
okay
so joe um now you're gonna have to carry
the rest of the show cause i'm all out
of jokes
i thought you did a great job i mean you
killed it on that monologue right i mean
it was
i i mean i've been working for greg for
six months now and i think you're the
funnier of the two but
but greg is uh he's my boss he's in
charge of how much i get paid i just
wanted to give him a heartfelt message
on his birthday that just ex off the
cuff here
greg gutfeld is a handsome
daring leader that will shepherd america
to victory in the fight against
communism
[Laughter]
i agree with that oh
she is also my boss
now i don't have to kiss his ass cause
he's not my boss
now curtis speaking of communism you're
fighting against it running for mayor
here in new york
you were mentioning to me in the green
room that you were really glad guttfeld
wasn't here and i was hosting because
that could hurt your campaign so you're
welcome um uh jesse jesse we we never
had that conversation
you have a very elaborate imagination we
did not have that conversation that's
true i just lied yes
i'm getting the feel of the show now all
you got to do is shake hands kiss a baby
and you too can be a politician
i couldn't take the pay cut
kdp
does greg make you nervous
uh sometimes yes because i'm always
trying to manage greg's complaints and
my number one goal in life is to have
him not complain about me so i like when
he complains about you instead that's
true which is all the time greg
complains about everything and i'm sure
he's going to be complaining about this
show
um cat anything you want to say to gut
fell because as i said he doesn't have
anything else going on he is watching
right now but the thing is i have the
exact same focus in life as katie yeah
we're all worried about it the less that
he complains the better so
happy birthday greg happy happy birthday
happy 60th birthday greg
not that far off hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else